you mentioned happiness being one of
your top priorities what is happiness to
you like what does that mean what does
that word mean can you unpack that
yeah it's a very evolving thing i think
like all the great questions
um you know when you're when you're a
little kid you go to your mom and you
say what happens when we die is there
santa claus is there god should i be
happy you know who should i hurry those
kinds of things there are no glib
answers to that because there are no
there are no answers that apply to
everybody
um so these these questions the search
for truth you know these kinds of
questions they ultimately do have
answers but they have personal answers
so the answer that works for me is going
to be nonsense to you and vice versa
so whatever happiness means to me it
means something different to you and it
means something different to the
listener
but i think it's very important to
explore what it is and for some people i
know it's a flow state for some people's
satisfaction
for some people it's a feeling of
contentment
the best my definition keeps evolving
so the answer would have given you a
year ago would be different than what i
tell you now
but today i believe that happiness is
it's really a default state it's what's
there when you remove the sense that
something is missing in your life
uh and we are highly judgmental survival
and replication machines we're
constantly walking around thinking i
need this i need that trapped in the web
of desires and happiness is that state
when nothing is missing and when nothing
is missing your mind shuts down and your
mind stops running into the future or
running into the past to regret
something or to plan something and then
in that absence for a moment you have
internal silence and when you have
internal silence then you are content
and you're happy uh i i think
people believe mistakenly uh you know
feel free to disagree because again it's
different for everybody but people
believe mistakenly that happiness is
about positive thoughts and positive
actions
but the more i read the more i've
learned the more of experience because i
verify this for myself
every positive thought essentially holds
within a negative thought in the
contrast to something negative but dao
de ching says it's more articulate than
i ever could but
it's all it's all duality and polarity
so if i say i'm happy that means that i
was sad at some point if i say uh he's
attractive then that means that somebody
else is unattractive
so every positive thought even has a
seed of a negative thought within it and
vice versa
which is why a lot of greatness in life
comes out of suffering you have to view
the negative before you can aspire to
and then appreciate the positive so all
that said long-winded to me happiness is
not about positive thoughts it's not
about negative thoughts it's about the
absence of desire especially the absence
of desire for external things
and so the fewer desires i can have the
happier i can or the more i can accept
the current state of things the less my
mind is moving because the mind really
exists in motion towards the future of
the past the more present i am the
happier and more content i will be but
if i latch on to that if i say oh i'm
happy now and i want to stay happy then
i'm going to drop out of that happiness
because now suddenly the mind is moving
it's trying to attach to something it's
trying to create a permanent situation
out of a temporary situation
so happiness to me
is mainly not suffering not desiring not
thinking too much about the future of
the past really embracing the present
moment and the reality of what is the
way it is
because nature has no concept of
happiness or unhappiness to a tree there
is no right or wrong there is no good or
bad uh you know nature follows
unbroken mathematical laws in the chain
of cause and effect from the big bang to
now
and everything is perfect exactly the
way it is it's only in our particular
minds that we're unhappy or not happy uh
and things are perfect or imperfect uh
because of what we desire uh but i think
i've also come to believe in the
complete and utter insignificance of the
self and i think that helps a lot like
for example if you thought you were the
most important thing in the universe
then you would have to bend the entire
universe to your will because if you're
the most important thing in the universe
then how could it not conform to your
desires and if it doesn't conform to
your desire something's wrong however if
you view yourself as a temp bacteria or
an amoeba or if you view all of your
works as writing on water or building
castles in the sand then you have no
expectation from how life should
actually be life is just the way it is
and then you sort of accept that and you
have no cause to be happy or unhappy
those things almost don't apply and what
you're left with in that neutral state
is not neutrality i think people think
oh that would be a very bland existence
no this is the existence that little
children live and if you look at little
children on balance they're generally
pretty happy
because they're really immersed into the
environment at the moment without any
thought of how it should be given their
personal preferences and desires
so i think the neutral state is actually
a perfection state
and one can be very happy as long as one
isn't too caught up in their own heads
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you